this term is when we're going to
introduce to you just shortly before
your next assessment task I know you
just got out of synthesis of darts but
know what make sure you're headed in the
right direction but pointy exorcism
tasks and we'll finally meet that big
topic I've been around for a long time
and calculus meet the first idea we did
which is called differentiation limits
best principles are confi when we deal
with these indices is the first major
kind of foundational idea but you just
have to know just like and type tables
you know what you're doing fractions and
you have to add something like say these
guys right this is not about times
tables but if you do not do your times
tables your access this is so
restrictive because in order to cross
solve especially what do you have to do
times you have to you have to get a
common denominator don't you which
requires the multiplication of these two
numbers so if you cannot look at that in
the pink 21 without even really devoting
much conscious thought to it then
obviously you will find fracture is very
difficult okay it's kind of same deal
with indices when you're first moving
into calculus and you're dealing with
this idea of differentiation and all
that kind of thing
indices are going to come up just like
times tables are going to come up in
fractions okay so I want to make sure
you are fluent in those and confident
and quick and accurate that's what this
is about
okay know your next source is really
going to start you guys know a whole
bunch of index laws I don't need to work
them all out for you bless you I wonder
if you guys can help me actually list
them out in any order I'm not really
fussed can someone give me an example of
something which you just know takes me
fact when you're dealing with indices
someone anyone Eric go ahead give me one
okay fantastic anything raised to the
power of zero equals one this is a bit
of a weird one right how would you go
about proving this by the way how would
you go about trying to convince someone
I can't you raise 18 mm area it's gonna
be one yeah okay so you could appeal to
box for this how got a will point out we
learn indices first then we come to logs
second so even though I could do this
it's a little awkward because this is
usually the foundation for logs not the
other way around though it is a valid
way of doing it as we get to later so I
want to give you another suggestion
there someone want to help me work out
because what Eric's about to refer to is
another index law because someone
articulate than what he's talking about
yes okay so you can give me an example
can anyone give me the war that actually
states what so this is what you're
giving me is a special Pacific case that
will get you to this but if we want to
speak or generally you can actually have
numbers with the same base and any power
watts so we'll just call that Y I guess
right and then what's the result
so when you divide numbers with the same
pace you subtract their powers by the
way that has a flip side this is
actually usually the harder version
what's the easier version of this not
division but multiplication so if
instead of dividing numbers of the same
as you multiplied them you're going to
have unity okay so now we had a few
attempts at it already
how would you use either of these to
prove the first index Lloyd over there
hey you started to get there when we
write this step what would you here's
one of the funny things right laws was
in mathematics and science are very
different from mores in like in society
right laws this society are we want
something arranged a particular way so
that you know things work best you know
people don't kill each other or steal
from each other etc but in many senses
those robber traitor right driving a
lesson inside the road driving right
inside the road does it really matter it
actually easily could be the other way
but laws like the index laws I'm not
like that
it's not like we can just decide what
should a to the zero be right this
follows on naturally from our
definitions of what indices ah there's
no there's nothing else it could be
right so the wars are what we emerge
what we observe almost all right you got
any other index laws for me that's three
[Music]
okay so this is the power power of the
power what are you going to get at the
other end a ^ very good okay
now by the way I will point out because
a few people ran up against this this
morning this is quite a actually no I'm
gonna wait till the next one wait to the
new I want to think about what happens
when you've never raised another thing
to a power if instead of a power is
racial power if you have like a product
that gets raised to a power what's that
gonna give you so the whole idea of
putting something in brackets is
whatever operations being applied to
this thing applies to the whole thing so
this power of X were applying to both of
those now this is the one we ran up
against we're pretty good are going from
left to right not so good at going from
right to left that seemed far less often
okay I can't read the exact example but
I think someone showed me this something
like this I don't know something of that
nature way x and y are some random bits
and pieces in it okay you can see here
that this is an instance of this are a
and B are any numbers you like so I'll
just put X&Y there what are the powers
here so this is 1/5 right which by the
way is another one about in Nick's laws
how would you state that generally
speaking how do you relate roots I was
gonna say square roots but any roots
with indices yeah yeah sure yeah
the wife Ruth yeah yeah that just rolls
off the tongue right yeah
the winery I will say usually the way
this is stated just to make it a little
easier to say is if you've got a to
power of one over N that's the m3 leg
right second third fourth whatever so as
you pointed out this is X to the fifth
this is y to the fifth so we're quite
good at recognizing when the bases are
the same we know what to do in the
indices right but if the powers if the
indices if the exponents are the same
you can also rewind this law and combine
them right do you notice that so what
would we write in this case yeah this is
something you've intuitively be dealing
with for quite a while one more color in
the very specific cases square roots
right in fact way before you were really
thinking about index laws in a proper
way you knew what to do with this right
three times repeat what would you say
that it so long as ampere positive
that's true okay so this and this are
just a special version top of this right
this is the expansion this is the
factorization okay what do you think
have we got all the index laws are we
missing any
there are negative indices right someone
hasn't said anything yet what can we do
how would we stay next to do with
negative innocent sleep and again what
this comes from is actually probably
this one is from the easiest way to
state it right well you are dividing if
you divide by successive terms
eventually you'll get a negative which
but dividing and dividing and dividing
is another way of writing a fraction
okay so we know these are speaking a
common language so far so good now each
of these index laws has a flipside right
which is why I've stated this having as
indices and logged every index law gives
birth to a log law sumit easy some are a
little more complicated so I'm just
gonna roll off this example stuff over
here every one of these has a parallel I
wonder if you can work that out summer
like I said are easy one more thing
which I just but it's important for our
log laws in a second okay let's start
with say the top one which is the first
one you gave me there's a world war that
goes with that index world how would you
say it I'll give you a clue it starts
with log yeah so I would usually say
even though I understood what you meant
to it was obviously clear but I would
tend to read that left to right so I'd
say log base a of one taking the log of
one so long as you say the right words
particularly safe basis then I know
exactly we know log base a of one is
equal to so what you've done is you've
taken this right and all you've done is
rewrite this initial exposure equation
this exponential equation it's got an
exponent in it
and as a long equation you've just
rearranged and out pops this in other
words log of base any field of one
equals zero so far so good
have a look I'll let you take any of
them in any order that you like give me
another log law that comes out of any of
those indexes yep
wish log base a like that yeah yep
okay someone comes in here how does it
how does it finish really William okay
so you can sort of see it there and this
is why I'm trying to highlight that
these come together they come in pairs
right when you divide numbers of the
same base you subtract they're a disease
when you subtract logs of the same base
you divide there now this thing in here
has a bunch of different names the
technique Renee would probably be useful
here is argument but that actually means
a whole bunch of different things so I'm
just going to say you divide the part
that you're taking the log off that's
the actual number okay yeah hey you guys
suggestion or a question yeah okay well
let's do it right again here when you
multiply numbers in the same base you
and their embassies so if you add Logs
with the same base what do you do
you multiply brackets a point okay
what's your starting to get the hang of
it right what I'm gonna get you to do is
I'm gonna pause there
I'm going to ask you to either go back
to that worksheet that you were working
on this morning
or if you have finished it I'd like you
to open up to six a six a in your
premium techno
and I want you to have a go at using
these for a challenge if you really want
it you can try and state the log holes
for all of these that correspond and
then we'll come back together about ten
minutes